european union home affairs ministers
have examined ways to prevent
tragedies in the mediterranean sea as
would-be immigrants head for europe's
shores
in poorly maintained boats the ministers
looked at what steps they can take in
the short term
to help avoid tragedies like the one off
the island of lampedusa in october
the debate was based on priority actions
identified by the task force for the
mediterranean
these include increased cooperation with
third countries
better protection and resettlement
measures boosting the fight against
trafficking and smuggling
tougher border surveillance and more
solidarity with member states under high
migration pressure
the tragedies at sea will be a focus
when european leaders meet in brussels
in june
ministers also had in-depth talks on the
issue of fighters from europe crossing
into syria
to join the conflict there most of them
alongside jihadist groups
they looked at ways to better prevent
the recruitment of europeans
improve information exchange beef up the
criminal justice response and boost
cooperation with
other countries concerned the flow of
foreign fighters traveling to syria from
the eu and other countries has been
gradually rising
and some could pose a security threat
when they return home
for justice ministers data protection
was a priority concern
they discussed new ways to better
protect personal information
notably the so-called one-stop shop
principle
it would see one national authority
monitor businesses or organizations that
process
personal data in more than one country
ideally the authority in the state where
the business operates
the ministers underlined the need to
ensure that quality reforms are put in
place
which would improve the internal market
and the competitiveness of european
companies
without sacrificing privacy